hey y'all scotty mccreery and you're
watching certified country with Sophie
shall I see
[Music]
happy Friday welcome back to certified
country today we're hanging with two of
my favorite reality TV alums that is
scotty mccreery and raelynne and later
i've got a special treat for y'all in
the form of an exclusive bret young
video premiere now I just met him for
the very first time and let me tell you
he is very tall and very handsome so
you're gonna want to stick around for
that one but first things first kicking
it off with American Idols season 10
winner
Scotty McCreery just signed a brand new
record deal with Sony Music
Entertainment's triple tigers records
after he made history with his new
single changing
[Music]
it's the first ever independently
released song to chart on the country
air track media base top 50 I'm it up
with Scottie in Nashville to catch up
over happy hour the song is all about
thinking back to you know past times we
just went through a whole lot of home
video 50 hours of home video and found
like 4 minutes worth of it that was good
my favorite part of the whole thing is
when it goes back to you but pictures of
me my girlfriend because we met in
kindergarten so it's our kindergarten
picture there with both of us in it and
then it shows our prom picture than us
today so she's good she's having a good
time today I heard from her so that
means she's having fun what'd she get
starstruck by she saw Luke Bryan a
couple years back and I introduced it to
her her name's could be and he said oh
hey Debbie he just didn't quite nail it
didn't quite nail it but it was
hilarious
[Music]
now we got to talk about Idol yeah
coming back do you feel like it came
back too soon I personally thought I was
gonna be away for a little bit longer
but you know hey it's all good I'm a fan
of the show what do you think of Katy
Perry as the new anchor judge I'm all
about it I've always wanted to meet her
so don't let me come back and check out
show so now she's awesome I mean she's a
huge star and I think she'll give read
advice now are you gonna be a part of it
are we gonna see you they have to bring
you back they give me a ring I'll
definitely check it out I think I'd be
better folks are asking like would you
be a judge I think every better as a
mentor like he's kind of helping folks
out looking back on that experience what
do you remember the most that was the
most applicable piece of advice or
wisdom always have Jennifer Lopez around
no American Idol stuff I would love that
but no I think it would really was a
boot camp for for all of this you know
this is a crazy business here in
Nashville and it's it never ends never
stops got to work hard you gotta
persevere you got to wake up every
morning being ready to go and its ups
and downs just gotta keep on rolling
worst part about being out on Idol I
would say I was there for about three to
four months and we have one day off the
whole time and so and I want to go to
baseball game they wouldn't let me so
that that was bad
[Music]
the good
what do you like to drink you know I
tell you what in last few months I've
really gotten into wine I used to hate
it and you know I think you know palates
changed everything started with white
wine now I love red wine so I kind of uh
everything is good by me now this one is
not on my list but I'm just personally
curious one word to describe yourself
after a few drinks huh weird yeah yeah
very cool thank you that was so much fun
best interview have had beers yay well
cheers to that Scotty is working on his
next album and I'm told to expect it out
sometime in 2018 in the meantime of
course he is out on the road and you can
find all his tour dates up on his
website meanwhile an alum of Team
Sheldon over on the voice rail in hit
number one on Billboard's Country Albums
Chart with her debut wild horse
earlier this year now she also just so
happens to be truly one of the most fun
people to interview
[Music]
we got to talk about your gems on your I
always forget
always think it's an eye booger and I
just when you get it out I'm like that's
really a gem so let's not take that it's
cool if it were me I would have glitter
just all over my face put my facing
under and just come up you know I mean
anything that sparkly your looks airing
this and her like a unicorn out how
where they want it I was just gonna say
I think your aesthetic is unicorn yeah
like quite simply put it's so funny
anytime I get a gift from a fan like I'm
guessing one to ten that something in
here is definitely unicorn life you must
have quite the unicorn collection girl
I've gotta figure something out with all
this stuff so last time we really sat
down and talked wild horse was coming
out we were so excited about it now cut
to number one debut know how crazy is
that it's you know when I see something
like that happen I just see all the hard
work that I've done in the last five
years pay off and I've been working at
this for so long meeting you know so
many fans every night and planting seeds
just every single day whether it be a
coffee date with a you know a new writer
in town or meeting with a new producer
meeting a fan that's in town just
because they were you know a fan of me
since the voice like all these little
seasons I've planted they've all just
grown and it's just cool to see you know
it all come together with a number-one
record you know and you know it's I
can't even take the credit for it
because it's because of the fans
[Music]
I know you're always working on yeah
right God why are your in a bajillion
new songs yeah
going through this new phase of life of
being just madly in love and just my
husband being gone and just growing so
much together and in that way like I've
just written so many awesome like really
cool love songs that I've never thought
like that I could write and I'm really
excited about them I'm so happy for
everything I love you all right the time
has come for a certified country
exclusive I am so excited to give you
guys a sneak peek of this acoustic
performance from mr. Bret young we also
met up for a quick chat at the Ryman
in-between rehearsals for ACM honors
without further ado here's Brad
[Music]
you know when you can't take it back
[Music]
you know the inspiration behind
left-sided leaving was just you know
coming to the realization that breakups
always seem to be unequally weighted and
and that everybody's probably been on
both sides at some at some point or
another in their life and you know the
kind of interesting way that somebody
who you know has their heart broken
seems to behave after a breakup talk to
me about the album as a whole I'm a
songwriter first and I wanted so badly
for there to be this consistent theme
throughout the record and as we tried to
do that we started realizing that some
of our favorite songs were getting left
out we finally decided you know what
this isn't kind of the first time I'm
introducing myself to the like the whole
country music audience let's make a
record that shows them Who I am as a
person rather than trying to make this
theme thread throughout the record no
just getting to hear so long if you want
to you can get to know me a little bit
baby I'll be staying
you have an interesting backstory and
you were originally an athlete I played
baseball all the way through college
ended up hurting myself my junior year
in college and not rehabilitating in
time to come back and play and it was
like through that process of trying to
figure out you know when something that
you think is gonna be your whole life is
taken away from you
what your outlet gonna be now and that's
when I really dope into music and
started songwriting it must be nice to
be talented in multiple capacities of
life but when did you just or when did
you discover that you really had an act
for songwriting I wrote my first five
records by myself as good as that was
for me in terms of like you know being
cathartic and letting me work through
some of my stuff I wasn't really growing
as a songwriter because there was nobody
pushing me or holding the outside of my
comfort zone it took me ten years of
songwriting to figure out that I needed
help and I'm so glad that I wasn't you
know I didn't fight that too hard
because the you know the songs that
we're turning out now are just I'm so
proud of them to see the full acoustic
performance of left side of leaving
click over to et online.com and look for
the music section right up top I got a
run because we are taking certified
country on the road again next week do
not miss it you guys I am serious in the
meantime have a wonderful weekend and be
sure to click like and subscribe for
more bye for now